[موسيقى]
نرحب بمشاهدينا في كل مكان وبضيوف
البرنامج الذي لا تشاهدونهم على الشاشه
ويمكنك من تتفاعل معهم على صفحتنا على
فيسبوك وعلى صفحه البرنامج على تويتر نقاش
هنا اتفاق الاطار الذي وقعته قوى معارضه
في السودان مع العسكريين من اجل احتواء
الازمه السياسيه في البلاد اتفاق يرثه على
تشكيل حكومه مدنيه لا صلاحيته واسعه
وتشكيل مجلس للسياده برئاسه مدنيه كل ذلك
لفتره انتقاليه على امتداد سنتين عده قوى
معارضه تؤيد الاتفاق واخرى ترفضه وتطالب
بمحاسبه العسكريين والاستمرار في
الاحتجاجات دول مثل الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا والسعوديه ومصر وتركيا وغيرها
من الدول رحبت بالاتفاق ولكن هل سينهي
فعلا حاله الانقسام والتجاذبات هل سيلتزم
العسكر بتنفيذ كافه بروده سعيد بن ناقش
الموضوع معي هنا في الاستوديو زينب محمود
دبي قياديه في الحركه الشعبيه لتحرير
السودان سعيد بان يكون معنا من الخرطوم
مهدي رابح وقياده في قوى الحريه
وسعيد بان يكون معي من لندن نزار عبد
العزيز الامين العام للجبهه الوطنيه
العريضه في بريطانيا اهلا وسهلا بكم قبل
ان نبدا نستمع لما قاله عبد الفتاح
البرياني
التزامنا على خروج المؤسسه العسكريه من
العمليه السياسيه نهائيا
هذا الامر
ان يصاحبه خروج القوى السياسيه من
المشاركه في مرحله انتقاليه
استجابه لمطلب الثوار
وماذا قال محمد حمدان الدكلو شهير حمدي
اوليه واساسيه لمعايده الاخطاء السياسيه
ومعالجه الاختلالات اختلالات الدوله وبناء
دوله العداله
بما ان الخبر في الخرطوم يبدا معك ضيف من
الخرطوم مهدي رابح قيادي في قوى الحريه
والتغيير خلاص هذا الاتفاق نهائي ينهي
حاله التجاذبات ينهي الانقسامات دخلنا في
مرحله جديده تبدا منذ تعيين رئيس الوزراء
شكرا استاذ توفيق ومرحبا بالمشاهدين
ومبروك للشعب المغربي ااا بدايه
هذا الاتفاق وليس نهايه وبدايه خطوات
متعدده وعسيره وفي غايه التعقيد لاستعاده
مسار الانتقال الديمقراطي فكما تعلمون فقط
قطع انقلاب الخامس والعشرين من اكتوبر في
العمل الماضي همم المسار الانتقال وقامت
قوات
الانقلابيه باعتقال القيادات المدنيه
تمزيق الدستور عمليا
ومحاوله اقامه همم نظام ديكتاتوري جديد
همم وايجاد شرعيه له عبر طرق متعدده همم
ولكن قبل هذا النظام الديكتاتور الجديد
همم شعبي منذ اول دقائق يعني الاعلانه
الانقلاب
وباعزله دوليه شامله وفي الحقيقه يعني ادى
هذا الانقلاب عبر 14 شهرا همم طويله
وعسيره همم الى الى ظهور يعني
تجليات لتفكك بدايه تفكك الدوله السودانيه
فحاليا نحن لا نعيشه تحت مظله دوله وحكومه
واحده وموحده نحن حاليا نعيش فيما يشبه
يشبه التحالف من الدويلات لكل دويله جيشها
الخاص ولكل دويله مركز قرارها الخاص
وعلاقاتها الخارجيه وحلفائها الخارجيين
همم وهذا يمثل خطرا ومهددا كبير جدا همم
لمستقبل السودان
الحراك الثوري المقاوم همم لهذا الانقلاب
همم
الشمولي او الشموليه بصوره عامه لم يتوقف
همم ولا للحظه ولا ليوم واحد لمدى 14 شهرا
همم وراحه ضحيه القمعه المفرط ما يزيد عن
119 شهيد والالاف الجرحى دفعوا ثمنا غاليا
اا من اجل مقاومه همم هذا النظام
الاستبداد الجديد
جدا البرنامج
شكرا جدا جدا شكرا شكرا استاذ زينب ومرحب
استاذ زينب
سلام ومرحب بضيوفك الكرام استاذ توفيق
وبرده نبارك للمغرب للشعب المغربي بالفوز
في همم اليوم احنا كلنا فرحانين بالفوز ده
حقيقه ان الكلام اللي انت يعني حاولت
تقوله وهو في يعني جميل جدا وان احنا
تعودنا كالسدانين نسمع كثير من ال همم من
الجمل الجميله والبراقه وفي نفس الوقت
برده الاتفاجات الكثيره بالواقعه كله مره
همم في مضمون كلامك انت قلت الانقلاب
العسكري همم
في نفس الوقت برده تكلمت عن دوايات كثيره
يعني حاله السودان كلام انا ما باعرف هل
الاتفاق الذي وقع اليوم
اذا تم تنفيذه هيعيد ترتيب الاشياء لدوله
نحو الديمقراطيه لانه همم يعني هذا
الاتفاق هو عباره عن بنود نصوص مكتوبه ما
في اي مخاطبه لجذور الازمه السوداني
والمشاكل السوداني الحقيقيه التي اخرجت
الشارع السوداني اضافه لانه المعترضين على
الاتفاق قد يكون حتى نحن يمكننا يعني
اتفاجئ يمكن القى في التلفزيون اليوم في
حدا مؤيد الاتفاق لكن كل شارع السوداني
معظم السودانيين في الشارع ضد الاتفاق
حاجه يعني حاجه
وخيانه الشارع وخيانه الثوره وخيانه
مصريات الثوره حتى الدفاع عنه حاجه بجد
اكثر من صعبه يعني طيب نزار نزار عبد
العزيز
السودان
بهذا الانتصار الجميل العريض همم لاول
فريق العربي لهذه المرحله هو ده الحقيقه
يعني نحن في الجبل الوطنيه
الايطالي لاجهاض وتصفيه الثوره للاسف
الشديد هو كذلك من مسمياتي لانها هذه
مسؤوليه وطنيه واخلاقيه وتاريخيه وسياسيه
سيسال الشعب السوداني منها ولهذا النضال
التراكم فلا يعقل عقلا ويستقيم ان ناتي في
اخر الامر ان نوقع مع هؤلاء العسكريين
هؤلاء القتله هؤلاء اللجنه الامنيه
المعزول البشير التي لا زالت المستمره في
الحكم الى الان ولا تتوقع بانها سوف تقضي
الى التحول الى الحكم المدني الديموغرافي
رغم من الكلمات الناقه والرماقه التي
يتحدثون بها لكن حقيقه همم وايضا لابد من
التحيه للهلال والاكبار لهذا الشعب البطن
وهؤلاء الثوار وقوه الصغرى والمناظرين همم
نعم نعم
انه الثوره الثوره الناجحه لا تقبل
التغيير الجزئي اول مرحله او تقبل التغيير
الكامل لتصفيه الجبهه الاسلاميه القوميه
التي لا زال توسيطر على الدوله السودانيه
بالكامل منذ 89 والى الان هي الدوله
العميقه المستمره فهذه الثوره الناجحه نحن
كمان رايناها ولا سنكون زي الثوره
الفرنسيه
الشوارع فهذا تغيير جزئي وحلول جزئيه
نعم لا لا لا لان بقيه مداخلتي يعني كان
فيها رد يعني على على هذه التعليقات اولا
اا يعني الحريه والتغيير بالتحديد همم هي
يعني اول من تصدى للعسكريين همم منذر
بدايه ولو فعلا كانت طالبه للسلطه لا ما
حدث هذا الانقلاب فالانقلاب حدث على
الحريه والتغيير في المقام الاول
ومنذ حدوث هذا الانقلاب كان الموقف همم
والقوه والقوه الثوره اذا سمحت له باكمال
همم
انا انا انا انا ساشرح لك انا انا ساشرح
لك همم اذا سمحت لي
تفضل تفضل طيب
الحريه والتغيير منذ البدايه تبنت ثلاثه
ادوات لاستعاده لانهاء الانقلاب واستعاده
مسار الانتقال الديمقراطي المسار الاول هو
الحراك الثوري في الشارع وهي جزء منه جزء
لا ينفصل منه ومكمل لكل القوى الثوريه
الموجوده في الشارع ال- ال- الاداء
الثانيه الاداه الثانيه هو هي الحل
السياسي عبر الادوات السياسيه والثالثه هي
الدعم الاقليمي والدولي للقوه الديمقراطيه
للهلال الانقلاب واستعاده مساره الانتقال
همم الديمقراطي همم حاليا همم الوضع
المختلف قليلا لان التحالف الذي وقع
الاتفاق الاطاري هو التحالف اعرض من
الحريه والتغيير هنالك قوى يعني عديده همم
انضمت همم للتوقيع على
المسوده الدستور الانتقالي في البدايه همم
ثم همم الاعلان السياسي وبالامس الاتفاق
الايطالي
الانتقال الديمقراطي او التحول الديمقراطي
في السودان هو مثله هو مثل كل التحولات
الديمقراطيه التي حدثت في العالم خلال نصف
القرن السابق ليس هنالك تحول ديمقراطي
يحدث استجابه لشعارات براقه كالذي يعني
ذكرها اخونا نزار او لتخوين الرفاق في
الصف الثوري نحن لا نخونه
لكننا لكننا نضع وصلنا لكننا
لو سمحت لو سمحت
انا اسف انا ساقبل الجمله انا اعتذر
القوه التي تقف اليوم ضد الاتفاق الايطالي
وهو خطوه اولى يعني هو وليس ارتفاعا نهائي
من صنفين الصنفه الاول همم هو يختلف معنا
في الاهداف وهذا يعني انها قوه
شموليه في الاساس وهنا يمكن وضع
العسكرتاريا والاسلاماويين عناصر النظام
السابق واخرون لديهم مشاريع شموليه
والتحول الديمقراطي ليس في صالحهم
الصنف الثاني هي قوه ثوريه فعلا تزعى الى
التحول المدني الديمقراطي ولكن تختلف معنا
في اختيار الوسائل والادوات هي موجوده في
الشارع ووجودها احدى الشروط لنجاح عمليه
التحول على على المدى الطويل يجب ان يكون
ال- ال- الشارع
ويشكل ضخطا كبيرا على على
النظام الحاكم وعلى المنظومه الامنيه
والعسكريه التي تتبول على همم على العمليه
السياسيه والعمليه الاقتصاديه
هذه محافظه
الاطار
كان الشاملا
مهدي مهدي اي قضيه ولو كان هنالك اي خطا
قضيه همم يعني نحن لم تذكر في هذا الاتفاق
الاداري يجب ان تذكريها بالتحديد وليس
كلاما همم
لحظه بس لحظه بس انا سوزعلمه خلاص فعلوا
مع بعض كسودانين لان الموضوع يهكمكم كاس
سودانيين وبالتالي كل شخص اتفضل يتفاعل
معه
وهو يتحدث بطريقه
الروافده لهذا الاتفاق في انه يتفق همم
همم
حوريه
فهمتوا فهمت ما قلته الحاجه الضاره وضحها
لك انت ال ال المقيم معك في الاتفاق هي
ال- ال- ال- ال- القوه المؤقعه معك
الاتفاق هي اللي تعتبر قوه اسلاميه قوي
وشموليه قوه ترفض التغيير وهو ضد
الديمقراطيه وانت معك في هذا الاتفاق
والموقع
يا جماعه
فين 2012 عند حكومه البشير وهو ما كان
يدعو لها يدعو له المبعوث الامريكي
بالتسويه السياسيه والهبوط النائب هذا هو
كله هذه الاتفاقيه الان الوقعت معكم القوه
كما ذكرتها المؤتمر الذي انقلب على
الديمقراطيه 90 هو المؤتمر الشعبي الان
بالامس وقع معكم واليوم يدافع عن البشير
في في في في المحكمه فكيف يعقن ذلك بانك
تقول هذه ثوره هذه ثوره مختلفه
كيف ذلك
بنود الاتفاق هنالك كميه من النصوص
والفقرات بتتحدث حقيقه عن التحول
الديمقراطي وحتى هناك تحدث عن العلمانيه
حتى لو ما كانت ولكن فيما في مفهومه في
مفهومه هو العلمانيه
ههه فهذه طبعا قال انا بتكلم عن مثلا النص
زي العالماني والقوه المؤقعه على الاتفاق
هي قوه تتعارك تماما مع فكره العلمانيه
وبكل صراحه وبكل قوه صريحه في مساله
العلمانيه رايها واضح في مساله فصل الدين
عن الدوله او او ابعاد كما هو منصور عليه
في الاتفاق دي واحده خلي يعني انا اتكلم
عن مضمون فقره واضحه جدا
في هذا الاتفاق هذا يعني انك لم تطلع عليه
جيدا يعني
علاقه الدوله
على التناقض الذي يحصل القوه المؤقته بوضح
هنا هنالك تلاعب هنالك تلاعب بيتم كما كما
متعودين ان احنا كل مره هنالك يتلاعب يتم
لتصفيه الثوره السودانيه كما قال الاخذ
دعني اكمل كما قال الاخبار ذلك همم تلاعب
لتصفيه الثوره السودانيه من مضمونها
واعادتنا زي ما قالوا الناعم والهبوط
الناعم مساله العسكر هنالك همم انا افتكر
انه مساله العسكر هناك تحلل يتم على الشعب
السوداني بهذا العسكر هم ليس بعدين ما هي
العلاقه هل يعني هل يعقل هنا ليست هنالك
اي علاقه واضحه في بنود الاتفاق ما بين
القوه ما بين القوه ايوه القوه العسكريه
ما في نص بيوضح شكل العلاقه هذا في مجلس
سيادي مدني
نعم نعم يعني يبدو انك قراتي اتفاقا اخر
غير الذي وقع بالامس لكن الاتجاه هنا
رئيس
هنالك فقرات تتكلم عن خروج المؤسس
العسكريه السياسيه هنالك فقره تتكلم عن
الاصلاح الامني والعسكري هنالك فقره تتكلم
عن خروج المؤسسه العسكريه من العمليات
الاقتصاديه من النشاط الاقتصادي هنالك
فقره واضحه تتكلم عن الشرطه والامن
الداخلي انها تحت سيطره رئيس مجلس الوزراء
هنالك فقره واضحه تتكلم عن رئاسه رئيس
مجلس الوزراء لمجلس الامن والدفاع وهو
المجلس المعني تماما بالسياسات الدفاعيه
وهو الذي يراس القوات المسلحه بكافه
اشكالها
ذلك فقره واضحه ان راس الدوله المدني الذي
تختاره القوه المدنيه هو القائد الاعلى
لكل القوات
نعم الاعلى لكل القوه المسلحه
فكلامه يعني
[موسيقى]
هل هذا الاتفاق الايطالي
ولابد بالانتظار لمده سنتين حتى نرى ان
كان قادر على اعاده الثقه على الاقل في
الذين وقعوا في هذا الاتفاق امام الرفض هو
الرفض تام منذ البدايه دون اعطاء اي فرصه
لمن وقعوا على الاقل حتى يظهر حسن نيته
نحن لا نقف رفضا لمشروع وطني شامل نحن في
الجبهه الوطنيه
والرجل همم همم عليه رحمه الله داخل
الاعتصام القياده العامه قال شكله حكومتكم
من هذه الاعتصام ولدينا المشروع الوطني
كنا في واحد واحد 2019 في باقي القوى
الحريه والتغيير لكن خرجنا منها عندما
وقعت مع هذا النظام العسكري اول اللجنه
الامنيه التي للبشير فما هو المشروع
البرهان ليس لديه مشروع سياسي او ليس لديه
مشروع يعني كامل لحلول الوطن البرهان كان
احد الذين في انقلاب رمضان 90 وقد خان وقد
خانها هؤلاء العسكر خان البشير برده احنا
لو في 19 والان خانه مره اخرى في 25
اكتوبر وسيكونهم مره اخرى لانه البرهان
ليس لديه مشروع واضح انه هو المحافظه على
هيكله ومصالح الجيش الاقتصاديه والمصالح
همم الكبار الضباط في القوات المسلحه
وهؤلاء وهؤلاء كلهم يلطموا للتنظيم بتاع
المؤتمر الوطني ليس لانه الايدلوجيه الف
لا زعلت تسيطر على الجيش السوداني والامني
والشرطه والدفاع وكله اين همم كما ذكر
الاخ مجيد من الخرطوم يعني همم عن الهيكل
نسمع عن الهيكل ماذا حدث عندما مهدي عندما
كان حمادو رئيسا للوزراء كان هناك في قتل
الوزير الدستوريه كان هناك في طرف القبلي
لبعض المتظاهرين ماذا فعل عمده الان سياتي
رئيس وزراء سيكون في قطر لانه هؤلاء
الفنون وقاده النظام لا زال يتربصوا بهذه
الثوره المجيده هذه الثوره نحن نرفض
الحلول الجنسيه لابد من حال جذري لتصفيه
الدوله العميقه لتصفيه الجبهه الاسلاميه
القوميه من كافه مؤسسات الحكم المدني
والعسكري وامني وكلها
بعض التفصيلات يعني في همم
في الاتفاق الايطالي نعم هل حصلتم على
ضمنات خطيه واضحه من قبل المؤسسه العسكريه
وفي حضور ممثلين عن الاتحاد الافريقي
والامم المتحده هل حصل ذلك
ليس هنالك ليس هنالك ثقه في في في في اي
نصوص مكتوبه همم نحن همم نراهم في الحقيقه
على الشعب السعودي
في التغيير همم هذا هذا اولا هذا اولا
ونراهن على الحل السياسي همم الحصيف
والمعقد بمدى تحقيق هذه الازمه يعني
الانتقال الديمقراطي في كل العالم وحزمه
من العمليات غايه التعقيد والتي تحتاج الى
مدى زمن طويل وعلى راسها طبعا احنا في
حالتنا اللي هي عمليه الاصلاح القطاع
الامني والعسكري يعني في كل الدول حصل
فيها تحول مدني ديمقراطي لم يحدث بين ليله
وضحاها كما يعني يتمنى الاخ نزار يعني هي
تمنيات جميله لكن الواقع وفي كل العالم
اثبت ان عمليه التحول المدني الديمقراطي
هي مجموعه بدعه عمليات للتحول الاقتصاد
والاجتماعي والمؤسسي وفي حالتنا نحن همم
بالتحديد العمليه بتاعه الاصلاح الامني
والعسكري هي عمليه طويله تحتاج الى الى
مدى طويل والى مجهود جماعي والى صف مدني
موحد ال- ال- الضمانه الاساسي لنجاح عمليه
التغيير وحده الصفه المدني وعدم تكوين
بعضنا البعض اا بالنسبه
لو سمحتوا يعني
لبعض التفصيلات يعني للشرح يعني
الاتفاق الايطالي اذا سمحتي لاكون شاكر
يعني الاتفاق الايطالي هو اتفاق اولي قلت
ذلك في البدايه
الكلام وانت مش ملاحظ انه انت يعني بتاخذ
فرصه ثانيه
همم
اجراءات طويله كل الناس متفق على الحاجه
دي وعارفنا لكن انا لما نتحدث عن العمل ما
في علاقه واضحه انا ما بتكلم عن النصوص
لانه انا اكيد طبعا النصوص فيها اكيد كثير
من المبادئ جميله في بدايه المداخله
بتاعتك قال فيها كثير من المبادئه كويسه
للجميع لكن انا باتكلم
العلاقه الهيكليه يعني ما اول اتفاق ولا
اخر اتفاق لكن انا باتكلم عن علاقه
الهيكليه وبرهان في لقاءه في التلفزيون
العربي تساله سؤال مباشر همم الرئيس همم
السلطه هي دي هيكون مدني مجلس السياده
هيكون مدينه 10 واكد عليه انه هيكون مدني
هل هو حيعي هل هل بخلفيه عسكريه ولا مدني
لا هو ده المدني نفترض انه مدني مدني فول
مدني يعني نختارته من القوه المدنيه
همم
مش رئيس الوزراء من حقه يا عين ال- همم من
حجمه يتدخل في في في التعيينات العسكريه
ولا لا
في التليفزيون ده مش انا اللي قلته يعني
هو قال له الرئيس الرئيس السياده رئيس
الشرفي عليهم توصيات دي شكل العلاقه كده
هادي له توصيات من المجلس العسكري وهو
هيؤسس عليها خلاص قللت التحول التحول بتاع
الجيش الفقردي بالقاعده
بعدين لمن تجي الفرصه ممكن اشرح عليك انا
بالتفصيل كثير يعني
تحول الديمقراطي مساله معقده ومحتاجه
لحزمه
لكن في نفس الوقت محتاج لبدايه صحيحه انتم
البدايه البيضاء طبعا اخصائات مع ناس
موجودين معكم بس في الحكومه همم الموقرين
على الاتفاق جوه تم اخصائص
قلت لك المساله بتاعه التحول
بتاعه ايه
ههه شكلك بتسمعيني متاخر شويه ايوه محتاج
لي حزمه بتاعه اجراءات كل انا متفقين على
لكن هذه الحزمه يبقى تكون اجراءات صحيحه
وسليمه هنالك اخصائات تمت واضحه لقوه
موجوده معكم هالسفيه في في في همم في
عندكم حق واحد وغحتي اثنين
عشان اقدر ارد انا برهان لما عندما تحدث
برهان تحدث بكل ووضح انه لا اله لن يكون
هنالك اي اخصائي لاي قوى سياسيه الان كثير
من القوى السياسيه
انا بتكلم عن حاله الانقسام الذي يحدثها
هذا الاتفاق الانقسام في الشارع الذي
احدثها الانتفاخ لا
انا انت برهام ما في فرق بينك انت في نفس
الموقف اللي انا باضع فيه بادعك انت معه
في نفس الصف يعني
لكن هو الحريه
الاخطاء اللي احنا راجعين فيها اليوم
التي تقبل
لخطيئه
طيب انت تحدثت عن المسار يحتاج الى وقت
اذا متى سيتم تعيين رئيس الوزراء لان
الامور ستدخل حيز التنفيذ يعني من اليوم
الاول ننتظر سنتين حتى ندخل في مرحله
جديده من سيتدخل في تعيين الوزراء وكيف
ستتم عمليه التعيين
انا انا ساشرح الخطوات القادمه هذه هي
الخطوه الاولى الاتفاق الايطالي همم وداخل
الاتفاق الاداره هنالك همم اشاره لما بعد
تخص خمسه قضايا مهمه يجب الاتفاق حول
تفاصيلها قبل الوصول همم الى الى اتفاق
سياسي همم الاتفاق السياسي من المفترض ان
يحدث بعد شهر من الان همم وبعدها همم يتم
صياغه الدستور الانتقالي وتعيين همم رئيس
مجلس الوزراء همم همم
ورئيس مجلس الوزراء يتم اختياره من من
القوه الثوريه القوى الثوريه نحن في
تعريفنا هي كل القوه التي عملت على اسقاط
نظام البشير والتي قاومت نظام الخامس
والعشرين من اكتوبر
التي
وهي التي ستقوم وهي التي ستقوم باختيار
راس الدوله
ورئيس الوزراء بالتشاور مع قوه الانتقال
وقوى الانتقال نحن في تعريفها هي كل القوه
التي وقعت على على الاتفاق على الاعلان
السياسي همم ولاحقا على الاتفاق الاطاري
يتم التشاور معه لاكمال هياكل الدوله خلال
هاتين السنتين هنالك مهام محدوده للغايه
لكن اهمها هي بدايه عمليه الاصلاح الامني
والعسكري
همم الاصلاح الاصلاح المؤسسه النقديه همم
والاستعداد لانتخابات بعد 24 شهرا وهذا ما
ما نتمنى ان يحدث لكن ذلك يحتاج الى الى
دعم طبعا والى وحده الصفه المدني ومثل هذا
الخطاب خطاب التخوين همم
هذه المصالحات
هذه هذه
الوطن همم هي هي لا تساعد كثيرا يعني في
هذا في هذا الجهد
لو سمحت طيب
وضعتني في نفس ال همم في نفس المكان يعني
وهذه اشكاليه كبيره
همم
مهم جدا اه وهو ليس صحيحا انا اريد ان
اوضح يعني حاجه همم انت تحدثت عن همم عن
انه الرئيس همم الرئيس همم في المستوى
السيادي همم
ايوه هيتم التوافق بين القوى الثوريه في
اختيار وهذا لي صحيحا بين القوه الموقعه
على الاعلان السياسي وليس القوه السوريه
هو هذه يعني هذه
القويه
لكن التوافق بين القوه السوريه
موجود عندي قدامي
النص لو سمحت الرئيس مجلس الوزراء
القوى
المصريه
لكن هو الشخصيه المحوريه طبعا في عمليه
التحول كلها
السلطه الوطنيه
الاتفاق على اختيار رئيس الوزراء
الانتقالي بواسطه قوى الثوره الموقعه على
الاعلان السياسي وانت لما تقول هو الثوره
تخليها مفتوحه كده بتوهيم الشارع
السياسيه في انه عندكم الحق في اختيار
رئيس الوزراء وكانها عمليه ديمقراطيه وهذا
ليس صحيحا قوه الثوره الواقعه اللي هما
صار سنه المؤتمر الشعبي الجزائري معكم في
السلطه كلهم عندهم الحق في اختيار رئيس
الوزراء
انا لم اقول ان هنالك عمليه ديموقراطيه
هنالك عمليا انتقاليه فرق كبير يعني وحدي
همم من نقاط الضعف الكبير جدا في في كل
عمليات الانتقال في كل الفتره الانتقاليه
في العالم كله يعني ده دم عيار شامل انه
همم من هو في السلطه ليسوا موجودين على
اساس تفويض انتخابي وهنا من الضعف فعشان
كده الفتره الانتقاليه هسه
ويمكن همم ان تحدث فيها عقبات كبيره
كالنقلاب بتاع ال 25 من اكتوبر ومن هنا
يعني تاتي اهميه همم ضبط الخطاب السياسي
همم اولا عدم تخوينا الرفاق ودعم العمليه
السياسيه في وجهه نظرنا انه اختلاف وجهه
النظر همم في في اختيار الادوات لا يفسد
للاهداف قضيه لانه همم الهدف العام للشعب
السوداني بسرعه عامه هو دائر كتيرا الواقع
السودان داير يعيش في دوله مستقره دوله
ديموقراطيه فيها حريه فيها سياده حكم
القانون انا افتكر انه همم يعني الغالبيه
العظمى اذا استثنيتي بعض القوه الشموليه
وبعض
العسكريين اللي عندهم طموحات استبداديه
الشعب السوداني يرغب في في سودان جديد
سودان حرمه
الهدف واحد لكن اختيارا وسيله همم اختيار
الوسيله همم المختلفه ليس سببا للتخوي
يعني لتخوين الرفاق همم الذين
قالت جمله محدده يعني
نعم اوكي
قل لها كيس سكه الوطنيه مكتوب للجميع من
اراد اي فئه ثوره
لحظه عشان كده
بالضبط كده شكرا شكرا جزيلا هذا
الوطن شكرا
هذا اتهام بالخيانه الوطنيه
يعني وقت التلفزيون بالشعارات السامه
تفضل تفضل تفضل نحن في الجبل
عدم محاوره النظام او الجلوس
يعني ابدا لكن نلتقي مع الاخرين في رحاب
الوطن نلتقي معكم في رحاب الوطني لكن
يفتكر انه هذا تغيير جزئي وتغيير الجوزي
والثوره الناجحه ليس لها تغيير يعني تغيير
جذري فهذه اللجنه الامنيه التي كونها
المعزول البشير انت بتقول النظام سقط احنا
بنقول النظام لم يسقط من سقطه هو البشير
فقط واجلس النظام كما هو جالس الى الان
بكل مؤسساته بكل قواه المدنيه بكله كوادره
بكل في اللجنه في الامن في الجيش في
الدفاع في الشرطه في كوادر لا نراها
واشياك هذا وبعد انقلاب 25 خرجوا وهمم
ليتمكن من اول وجديد الاسلاميين في السلطه
ولا الان انا اعتقد بانه البرهان بذكاء
دخل الاسلاميين معكم عبر المؤتمر الشعبي
المؤتمر الشعبي يعني بيجيء القوه
المؤتمر الشعبي انا شخصيا مختلفه
لكن هم هم اذان الانقلاب منذ الخامس
والعشرين همم من اكتوبر وهم داعمين
للعمليه الديمقراطيه وهما موجود
89 في ناس قالوا سنه 69 همم
اوكي همم
في جزء منه صحيح جدا انه
منظومه او متبقي منظومه النظام السابق
وشبكات المصالح موجوده ولعبت دور كبير جدا
جدا في انقلاب الخامس والعشرين من اكتوبر
وحاليا هي ضد الحله السياسي بالمناسبات
وهذا يجب ان اا يجعلك يعني تضع علامات
استفهام كبيره همم مدى صحه هذا الحل
السياسي لان حاليا هي موقفه بنفس الموقف
المقاوم للحل السياسي نفس الموقف احنا يا
استاذ نزار لا نختلف في الاحداث كما قلته
نحن نلتقي في الوطن الفارق بيننا اننا
اخترنا الوسائل السياسيه الحل السياسي همم
وانت تختلف معنا في اختيار ال- ال- ال-
الوسائل نحن لا نختلف في القضاء نختلف في
طريقه الحل وفي الوسيله
الغايه النهائيه واحده انا انا متاكد منك
انا لا ارى ذلك ما اراه انكم همم
زين وراء ولا اتفاق هذا
يؤسسنا وراء السلطه كان همم ما كان
الانقلاب بتاع 25 اكتوبر بعدين ده ده
تاريخ جديد
قنوات الاخبار من من اغسطس 20 20 21 وشوفي
موقفنا كام كيف
والله
يا استاذ استاذ زين
اه
ضد الحريه والتغيير لانها كانت بتهدد
مصالح القوه الشموليه
والتغيير
اللي كانت اصلا موجوده مواقع على هذا
الاتفاق حسب البحث العربي من الاشتراك هل
هو يجوز من هذا الاتفاق حزب البحث العربي
هو ما هو موقع الاتفاق ماذا يعني هذا ماذا
يعني هذا هذا
محترمه جدا
من قوه الحريه
ولكن همم
ماذا يعني هذا ماذا يعني هذا للشعب
السوداني ولكل من حاجبه تماما ما هو نفس
الموقف احنا احنا بالنسبه الينا ال- ال-
التحالف الموجود ده هو اكبر تحالف سياسي
موجود فيه حزب الامه في التج على الاتحاد
كبيره في قوى ضخمه هو هو اكبر تحالف سياسي
سوداني حاليا كويس خروج البعثه الاشتراك
هو ارجو ان لا يحدث هذا لان هنالك نقاشات
كثيره همم لا يعني ان نغير الخط السياسي
والحل السياسي واذا حصل اختلاف كما ذكر
يعني
مجددا لتوضيح هذه النقطه لانها مهمه وليس
اختلاف في الغايات النهائيه وليس لها
اختلاف في حياتنا
اختلاف اختلاف في المسائل والادوات الخطا
والنتائج
بتعيطي ان احنا نطالب بالتغيير
الاستراتيجي ام معظم تغيير الاستراتي
الطريقه
لو سمحتوا لي يعني لو سمحت
الحركه التحرير ال- ال- السودان مش كده
حركه الشعبيه لتحرير السودان شعبيه
عبد العزيز الحلو ده شخصيه احنا انا شخصيا
محتارين جدا يعني رجل متخلف نزال
تلقائيات في الوسائل
ودسنا مختلفين في الغايات ولا اسمح لك انك
تشكك في وطنيتي
وطنيه
واحترم نضال يعني شخصيا لديه علاقات عميقه
يعني بعديده يعني
ولكن لا اقبل منك لا اقبل منك اشارات وطعن
همم يعني في وطني او في السلامه في حياتنا
الوطنيه
القضايا العامه لو
سمحتوا شخصا لانه انا احترمك ان الشخص لكن
اكبر لا اكبر من هذه الاتهامات
هذا خط احمر
تماما نزار هذا خط احمر
تلك المشاكل التي نحن فيها الان من
المشاكل العنصريه
والجهويه والقبليه
الان لم تتم هذه المعالجات وعلى اموال هذا
نحن رفضنا هذه الاتفاق هي لانها لا تعالج
غداء الوطن بصوره كامله او بصوره
مختلفون الحركات العسكريه
خارج هذا الاطار هذا خارج ال همم لا زالت
في وضعه هي كفاح مسلحه وهكذا لكن هذه احنا
نتفق انه لا لا هذا نحن لهذا النظام في
حركات مسلحه
خلطت في السلطه ثم الان تنتقد هذا الاتفاق
مع انها كانت في السلطه لما تم تم
طيب طيب
حركات كفاح مسلح
لانكم في هذه الوثيقه وفي هذا الايطار
ويكون في مناصبهم كما ذكر هذا البرهان لكن
للاسف الشديد انتم اذا مشيتوا للمجلس
الاتفاق جوبا
هلا الكره زمان
ما فيها اي اثنين ثلاثه لكن الموقف
كالسياسي انا لازم انتقده لانه ما بيمثل
انت وهو بيمثل الموقف بتاع الكتله بتاعتك
السياسيه العارضه وده الري سياسي يعني
ماما
اين وصلت الامور الشكر
في الحركه الشعبيه
الحريه والتغيير عبد العزيز على مين العام
اللي الجبل الوطنيه في بريطانيا شكرا
لفريق البرنامج رمسيس يا مريحه
[موسيقى]